gloria romano c'est l'inconnue la plus
célèbre du cinéma mondial
elle revient d'hollywood couverte de
lauriers de dollars avril à jean à la
sofia la claudia voici la gloria mécha
musiciens peuvent être faites pour ça je
suis moche yvette de nos conditions
finita je suis foutu la lumière qu'est
ce que c'est cette lumière de la police
ou quoi coût et sa noria romano vous
êtes blonde jolie sensuelle 6,6 après
votre premier film américain la presse
internationale a salué en vous une
nouvelle marilyn gloria reuben où
êtes-vous marilyn monroe à ça commence
pour les journalistes d'un terrible
pourquoi la marilyn toujours toujours
toujours c'est déjà douze femmes quelles
sont les marilyn dessus gloria pas nous
sommes beaucoup des blondes sur le monde
on vous a connu brume et ça change un
peu ça change un peu pourquoi non c'est
la vie tu peux plus me régaler avec les
cheveux noirs tirés semble a commencé
des études à cet animal comme eux mangé
ici en france la grenouille
oui la cannelle ou dans les mairies le
mari et marine et la grenouille le
crapaud est ce samedi à vélo avaient
semblé un crapaud vous êtes dynamique
vous comparez un écrin poussée du
masochisme et qui sait sa lettre les
parlements convenable
on part invité que je parle pas bien
attrapons vous acceptez mais marvin ça
ne semble pas vous enchanter qu'on vous
comparer m'enchante pas ça m'enchante
pas lé canal et canal je suis italienne
seront les petits points si les bleus
gagnent des biens ou la marilyn c'était
là alors stop s'est effectué ces mouches
là c'est pas je suis pas un homme c'est
les hommes qui parlent toujours sexy
mais vous y pensez vous accepté de
tourner des scènes très déshabillée
inquiète
j'accepte aussi est si j'accepte pas je
vais tout la vie à la bolognaise grèce
oui c'est gênant pour vous montrer tel
qu'on vous a vu dans votre dernier film
pas masqué avait même un doublé je
montre tout moi pourquoi tel que miyama
draine mamelles c'est pas d'accord elle
dit comme ça que je suis encore une
petite bande des problèmes mécaniques
route à vous déshabiller devant une
caméra c'est un supplice pour vous
appeler ça des opérateurs les photos un
peu aussi dans les magazines c'est bien
un bac aurait si c'est moi si je veux
faire aussi des photographies à la
doublure c'est elle qui passe
aujourd'hui à la télévision avec toi pas
moi c'est la vie c'est le contenu
préféré pour dormir
j'ai déjà entendu ça oui moi je dors
avec un tee shirt et aussi avec le pouce
dans la bouche comme l a dit kikis mama
les hommes ont-ils une grande importance
dans votre vie m'a dit hier le cd soit
des biens en france et les français sont
obsédés les italiens mais ça m'obsédait
les américains et sont fatigués
grand film italien en effet vous me fait
rire
geri triste ma commune grisonne on sait
très bien qu'un homme il vous à dimanche
et nous en italie les hommes à la la la
sofia et lapentti monique antonioni
claudio cristallerie giulia safely mais
qui ma may myo l'argent on me la donne
alors une femme gloria vous avez eu je
crois une enfance difficile
as tu peux parler son enfance maintenant
à la coupe maquilleuse anita aller en
amical à annie fait tu me souffle un peu
de la mangue concept pleuré un peu les
yeux
babet à peine un peu à peu la grâce
ça tourne
loria vous avez eue je croire une
enfance difficile en italie là bas petty
et demande à manger tous les jours en
italie
alors ma mère à profit la maman et papa
savait pas les papas alors moi moi